hey everyone this is Kim from the Trisha
website.com today we're gonna be
starting our coverage of the 2018 st.
Louis rapid and blitz tournaments part
of the 2018 grand chest tour and all
nine competitors from the grand chest
tour this year are competing in this
tournament - there is one wild card
that's gonna be Grandmaster Dominguez if
you're not familiar with this format we
play 27 rounds of chess over the next
week a lot of chess for these players
there's gonna be nine rounds of a rapid
chess both of these formats are fast
chest meaning you don't have a lot of
time for the entire match rapid is going
to be 25 minutes on your clock you get
10 seconds starting on move 1 for every
move that you make for the blitz portion
they're gonna play 18 games of blitz you
get 5 minutes on your clock in 3 seconds
per move starting on move 1 we will try
to have as much coverage of each round
as possible but there's a lot of rounds
each and every day at the end of
commentary for each of these games I
will give a overview a recap of each of
those rounds if you want to stay up to
speed you can watch these videos or I'll
have a link below of the official
website of this tournament so if you
want to follow along there as well you
can also watch live streams of this
event but in round 1 here playing the
white pieces we have Vichy anon and his
opponents playing the black pieces we
have Nakamura this she starts out with
pawn to e4 pawn e5 from Nakamura Knight
to f3 knight c6 Bishop to b5 Gideon's to
the right Lopez and as we've seen more
often than not the Berlin defense with
Knight to f6 pawn to d3 and then Bishop
to c5 usually gonna see Bishop to c5 or
pawn to d6 nakamora opting for a Bishop
to c5 Castle on the King side Knight
down to d4 attacking this Bishop here on
b5 nan decides to go ahead and exchange
in the center of the board pawn to c3
kicking the bishop back here to b6 and
now why it has a few
you have your normal pawn to d4 that's
one of the reasons you put your pawn
here and c3 is to push forward in the
center of the board
you could play Bishop to g5 pinning down
the knight to the Queen you could play
Queen to e2 y decides to go in and play
Knight to a3 preparing for Knight to c4
it's hacking the bishop up here on b6
and so we see black play pawn to c6
those two things one it kicks this
Bishop back it also opens up the door
for this dark square Bishop become to c7
as a safe-haven once the knight comes to
c4 so we see the bishop come back to a4
pawn to d6 what black could have also
castle on the King side Knight to c4 and
then the bishops gonna fall back here to
c7 now Bishop to b3 and you see this
many times once black has solidified his
pawn chains on these dark squares bring
the bishop here to b3 something Bobby
Fischer used to do quite often and just
have it hang out here really put a lot
of pressure on your opponent's King side
of the board this f7 Square in
particular the only piece that's
defending it right now is the King so
white looking to add pressure to that
especially in a rapid game where there's
not a lot of time you tend to find your
opponent's in some tough spots because
they don't have a lot of time to analyze
really all the certain variations that
they would like to pawn to h6 stopping
the bishop coming to g5 Knight comes
back here to e3 just preparing to come
to the King side of the board it came
here to c4 to attack the bishop but
decided not really doing anything right
now a lot of pawns stopping my
advancement so I'm gonna bring it to the
King side of the board pawn to d5 pawn
takes pawn recaptures punt up here to d4
and then pawn down here to e4 what kind
of stop and look at this position right
here
Black's done a good job of squeezing
white there's not a lot of places where
you know why can go a really go right
now there's a backward pawn here on d5
so that is something the black has to
worry about just keeping a lot of his
material defending that square you
always want to be
finding and it's hacking white/black is
gonna be defending this square both
sides do have the bishop pair I'd say
both sides are fairly equal in the board
states a white does need to be wary
about these pawns pushing forward but
you know there's ways to counter this
one of the ways is just to play pawn to
f3 and you tend to see this a lot in
rapid tile where you always want to have
a defense in front of your king but if
fish especially in these fast games
players are a little faster to push
pawns in front of their Kings because
they know that it's really a matter of
who's gonna make a big mistake and
they're not gonna put their king in some
crazy position and so as long as they
can just whatever's in front of them
right now and that right now is this
pawn on e4 then get rid of that they're
usually in an OK spot Queen comes down
here to d6 pawn to g3 since black is
threatening the Queen comes down here to
h2 and it's being defended with some
extra protection with the bishop here on
c7 a white is forced to play pawn to d3
and stop that attack now not Kimura to
science go and take this opportunity to
castle on the King side anon decided to
go ahead and break up this Center since
he did have a cramped position as we
talked about pawn recaptures and then
the knight comes up here to f5 attacking
the Queen now black has a few options as
far as how he could continue decides to
go and bring his Bishop down and capture
right here white nail does have the
bishop here where black does not if you
come take look back and say did black
have to do this well no he did it but he
couldn't play something like Queen to a6
if he's trying to hold on to his Bishop
here because Knight up here to e7 check
that is going to fork the bishop the
bishops going to fall and now if we come
back we could see the Queen move back
but it has to be careful does not want
to move to Queen to d7 because really
wants to have a defender on this Knight
to f6 the reason for that is the knight
can come here too
six check and the pond can't take
because the night's is going to be left
undefended the brook can come up here
you can see how different this is if
black decided to just play queen up here
to d8 now you're not going to see the
night take here because the pond can
take the nights being defended by the
Queen up here on da so could have if he
wanted to played Queen to d8 and then
you know Queen to e2 makes logical sense
from white but instead in the game
decides to go ahead and take the night
with the Bishop rook comes up here and
then rook over here to e8 and I think
this is a mistake from nock more if we
look at what white is trying to do here
the next phase of attack is to attack
this night here on f6 and so having more
defenders right now is what black should
be worried about
Bishop to d8 makes a lot of sense what
he doesn't want to do is exactly what he
did and that is to trap his rook here on
f8 because it can't go anywhere the
issue with that is now White has the
option of coming to f4
this is forcing the Queen to move a once
the Queen moves then we could just see
the rook take on f6 if the pawn takes
then Bishop coming up here to h6 and
this rook is trapped it's going to fall
White's gonna have a very very easy game
after this now what was just as
surprising as rook coming over here to
e8 is that anon did not play Bishop to
f4 he played at Bishop to e3 but luckily
for him Nakamura played you know about
as good of a move is his last one he
played pawn to h5 don't really think
this helps him at all if anything this
allows for white to execute is playing
easier because now the bishop comes to F
for the Queen's forced to move doesn't
really matter where it moves it's going
to come off the defense for this night
here the rook takes on f6 the pawn takes
the bishop takes here on c7 then after
the Queen take this Queen comes up here
to h5
with only a few minutes left on the
clock very tough for black to really
calculate how to continue here he
doesn't have any of his major material
over here on the kingside the board and
he's facing down a pretty aggressive
queen here he decided to go and push
with his pawn pawn III but then Queen to
g6 is just really tough to deal with you
can see this Bishop on b3 is coming back
to haunt black as this pawn is pinned
down and he can't move it because it's
being a legal move here so a nice little
way for white to gobble up some more
material here King to h8 Queen takes on
f6 check as well King moves you can just
go do that same thing over again it's
just difficult to have to worry about
the fact that you can't move that pawn
it's being pinned down King to h8 now
Queen to h6 difference of the move now
the bishop comes down here to see to
preparing for Queen to h7 checkmates
there's no real good way to deal with
this we see pawn to f5 this is really
just trying to save the game as much as
possible now Bishop to b3 so removing
that defender here on f7 it gets a
little tricky no real way to deal with
this except bringing the rooks involved
into the game we see rook over here to
e1 says yeah I can start to gobble up
material on a different front you still
can't move your rook it's pinned down
Black has no good moves here decides to
bring his queen over here to e7 trying
to double up on the e-file Queen to g6
check King here to f8 and now y decides
to go ahead and start exchanging
material on the board black is forced to
take with his queen Bishop takes and
after the King takes King to g2 and
black is forced to resign it's gonna be
easy for black or white to get his King
involved into the game up here to f3 he
can then take this material here on e3
the pawn can't come here because it
would just fall to the pawn here on at
g3 so Y would be up too much material
going into the very in game and Nakamura
also just didn't have a ton of time at
the end there so congratulations to
vision on you never
know what to expect in these long
formats with 27 games rapid style you
could tell early on neither side was
doing anything too crazy but then
fishing on found an opportunity and
capitalized on it and got the victory
now for the recap of around 1 because
we'll be trying to choose at least one
game from most of the rounds but for the
other rounds we did see
schecky Adama did off he beat Wesley so
and then Fabiano Caruana
he beat Alexander II shook those players
each got a those three players got a
victory in Game one along with you know
Vichy and not as we saw being the other
three so they are tied going into round
two but they started 30 minutes after
they ended around 1 so they are getting
in a few rounds each day and then once
they get into the blitz section I
believe it's 9 rounds each day just a
lot of chess since they are very very
fast game so hopefully you guys are
excited about this tournament always fun
to see the top level players playing
fast games because they don't have hours
to look over and make you know the best
move every time it's really just your
instincts kick in you have to go with
things you've learned over the years of
what feels best right now and so it's
interesting to see how that translates
from some of the openings we've seen
over time you know different variations
and how they can actually use those and
then you know go for victories we saw an
on from here so thanks for watching and
I'll see you guys in a future round of
the rapid and blitz tournament in st.
Louis